I'm going to level with you it's
challenging to get in any way excited
about the RTX 5070 uh let's put it this
way take the RTX 470 super actually a
pretty nice GPU right priced at $600 now
imagine a year later Nvidia releases
pretty much the same GPU with a $50
price cut and calls it a
5070 well that's okay I guess but it's
really hard to get enthusiastic about it
of course with this particular product
you do get D lss4 multiframe generation
and that has good utility except that
the effectiveness of multiframe
generation diminishes the less
processing power is available to it
meaning fewer options when compared to
say 570 TI or 80 and well there are
other problems too The Oddities of the
Blackwell architecture remain present
and correct here on 570 TI upwards this
resulted in less than Stellar gen on gen
gains and with the 5070 those Oddities
present as an actual gen on gen
regression against the 4070 super not
for every game but it is there and even
when it is faster we're mostly talking
about 6 to 8% faster which isn't exactly
gamechanging or indeed exciting in any
way Nvidia faces other problems too
beyond the reports of black screen
issues missing rops and the like AMD has
announced two gpus 9070 and 9070 XT
extrapolating out from their benchmarks
potentially the 9070 not only has more
memory than the 5070 but more
performance for the same sticker price
yes even with rate tracing meanwhile pay
a $50 premium and you get an AMD GPU
that is basically as potent as the much
more expensive 5070 ti so if you're
watching this review on day one the day
I posted it you'll probably know that
970 and 970 XT are embargoed until
tomorrow so we can't talk about numbers
there but everyone will be talking about
amd's answer to nvidia's 50 Series
lineup let's just put it that way and
I'm not sure it's going to be
particularly great news for Team Green I
have to admit though the RTX 570 is more
potent than I thought it would be based
on its specifications and here's why
from Blackwell so far typically we've
seen broadly equivalent performance per
cuic cor compared to the outgoing Ada
love lace architecture Blackwell uses
more power which does seem to account
for performance uplifts from the new
cards versus their 40 series
counterparts but here's how the specs
compare between 4070 4070 super and 5070
there are
6,144 cuticles with the 5070 an
improvement over the 470s 5,000
888 but not exactly a huge boost right
then Along Comes 4070 super with
7,168 cores now based on what we know
about Blackwell so far the 4070 super
should be a fair bit faster however the
5070 has more memory bandwidth thanks to
GD dr7 and a higher power budget but
still even with that in mind it is hard
to see it beating 470 super and yet with
some exception
and some of those regressions I was
talking about it does and of course you
can overclock it too let's take a look
at clocks and power draw then plus a
touch of overclocking which I'm
representing here with uh the power
budget set to 110% plus 350 MHz to the
core and plus 500 MHz to the memory 570
570 TI and 470 super all seem to operate
at much the same clock speeds overall
with the 507 consuming around 5% more
power than 470 super the 570 tops outed
around 213 Watts on average here in
Blackmouth ruk Kong um with 3.1 Jews per
frame up against the super at 3.2 Jews
per frame overclocking takes us north of
3 GHz for a 7.4% performance uplift at
the cost of an extra 7% in power but
that's still 3.1 Jews per frame there's
no crazy inefficiencies in using
overclocking here though I did note that
the founders Edition card did get
noticeably louder on the next tier up
however the 570 TI is 20% faster and is
actually more efficient at 2.9 jewles
per frame now let's look at cyberpunk
2077 in Psycho RT mode uh which isn't
hugely impressive the 5070 draws 12%
more power than the 4070 super for just
a 2 percentage Point performance
Advantage though overclocking does help
matters an 8.8% increase in performance
over stock translates to 11% more
performance over 4070 super and again
overall efficiency on the new card
doesn't change 5070 TI is 30% faster
here for just 133% more power so it's
clearly more efficient Metro Exodus
enhanced Edition has caused problems for
all iterations of Black World cards seen
so far the difference being that subpar
performance increases on all other 50
Series cards we've seen so far
translates into like for like
performance across the entirety of the
bench run the difference being that 5070
is using 10 to 11% more power making it
less efficient and this is really not
impressive again it takes an overclock
to pull the 5070 clear where we gain an
88.4% advantage 570 TI 23% faster but
it's using just 10% more power in this
example
a gut feeling here is that the 5070 and
this configuration of the GB 205
processor aren't particularly efficient
compared to Prior generation Nvidia and
clearly not as efficient as GB 203 in
the RTX 570 TI and similar to 5070 TI
and 580 I can't help but wonder whether
core clocks are being limited here as
the picture does look Rosier with
overclocking in place and Blackwell does
seem to easily operate at 3.0 to 3.1 GH
hurts now let's dig into more General
benchmarks and we'll kick off with
Avatar frontiers of Pandora a banana
skin game for Blackwell typically it
seems to run under par compared to adaah
and in this case that translates into an
actual win for the RTX 470 super which
at 1440p here delivers a 3% win
regression from jener gen is really not
a good look and there's a similar effect
at 1080p actually 200 more of your us
bucks notionally gets you a 570 TI which
is 24 points to the better well we can't
talk AMD today but I would expect to see
big price cuts on 7900 XT which is 11
points clear of 5070 and now let's look
back at older 70 series cards 5070 is 14
points ahead of the 4070 rising to 56%
clear of the 3070 and there's a 2.5x
performance multiplier against the 20 70
so clearly if you've got an older card
you're going to be seeing a big
difference with the new one right um
cyberpunk 20177 in Psycho RT mode sees a
mere 2% bump up from 4070 super while
570 TI Powers ahead with a 30 percentage
point lead but this game isn't so kind
to rdna 3 meaning that the notionally
discounted RX 7900 XT has just 76% of
the performance of the RTX 570
but well you know things may well change
once the RX 970 comes along and of
course MSRP on the 970 XT is just $50
more looking back up for IR 70 series
cards we're 20% ahead of the RTX 470 40
points clear of 3070 and there's a
whopping 3.1x performance increase over
the 2070 which seems to be suffering
from both RAM and compute deficits dying
like to in RT mode does kind of like
Blackwell actually but the 570 can still
only deliver a fivepoint lead over 470
super while the 7900 XT has 88% of 570
performance RT really isn't a strong
suit of Prior Generation rdna 3 but even
so it's not that far behind uh the 5070
here and of course we should expect big
changes ahead with 9070 and 9070 XT the
more expensive 5070 TI yields a 26
percentage point lead so proportionately
there is more value from the non-ti 570
here looking at prior generation 70
class Nvidia 25 points clear of 4070
rising to 65% ahead of the
370 and there's another 3.1x performance
multiplier against RTX
2070 I mean there's General
dissatisfaction with GPU prices and I
get it right but let's remember that
that 20 7 was only $20 cheaper than
today's
570 uh not one of nvidia's Finest Hours
um f124 next all RT features deployed
settings maxed yes it's another
Blackwell banana skin here with a 4070
super delivering a 5 percentage point
lead what this also means is that the
570 TI 31% ahead and even the 7900 XT
delivers a 20 percentage point lead all
is clearly not well with this one all of
this translates into a 10% advantage
over the 4070 which isn't particularly
amazing uh but there's clearly a problem
with the older cards perhaps because of
the 8 gigs of frame buffer memory 2.8
times performance advantage over the
3070 rising to a 4.2x boost compared to
2070 and weirdly some horrific
stuttering on the 3070 there which seems
to affect all resolutions but also
weirdly does not impact the RTX 2070
which has the same 8 GB of frame buffer
memory I mean let's put it this way if
your focus is narrowed to just Nvidia
cards and you've traditionally bought 70
series offerings but not the 4070 super
well the Gen on genen uplifts um do look
pretty good particularly from 20 and 30
series Indiana Jones and the great
circle NEX which demands a card with
Hardware accelerated R tracing features
again nothing or inspiring here with a
three-point lead over the 4070 super
while rad on RX 7900 XT eaks out a
three-point win of its own over the
5070 uh taken in average across the
bench of course scalability is odd on
this one with the 5070 TI only offering
up an 18 percentage point lead when MSRP
is 36% higher looking at prior
generation Nvidia cars of the same class
we've had to cut back texture pool
settings to medium for the 3070 and 2070
just to get it to run and even so uh
5070 commands a pretty substantial lead
53% ahead of 3070 rising to a 2.4x
performance boost over the 2070 which
despite the texture quality drop still
exhibits pretty poor frame pacing there
up against the 4070 nons super a 22p
point advantage to 50 Series here let's
look at some rasterization highlights
now the RTX 570 fares better against 470
super in black myth wuk Kong where I'm
logging a 10% performance lead with a
bit of a disappointing 19point Advantage
for the 5070 TI which of course has an
extra 36% on its sticker price um I
expected better from 7900 XT here
bearing in mind amd's rasterization
prowess but it only musts 95% of 5070
performance and I kind of thought it
would be better on the prior generation
group test the numbers do look better
than many of the previous results with a
28% lead for the 5070 over 4070 rising
to an impressive 75 percentage Point
advantage over
3070 and there's a 2.6x performance
boost over 2070 forer Horizon 5
continues to throw up some baffling
results but here it seems to Aid
Blackwell's cause as the 5070 scores 470
super by 177% which you know let's face
facts it's a big win compared to some of
the other results we've seen 570 TI
underwhelms again in this one with just
a 14-point lead while the 7900 XT pretty
much on par with 507s the new card's
only 1% faster taken as an average
across the whole sequence the news is
Rosia with the Gen on gen on gen on gen
results a 33o lead for 57 over 4070
rising to 85% over
3070 and you're getting a nice 2.6x
frame rate boost for 5070 over 2070
seriously if you're still on touring 40
series or 50 Series offers a big big
Improvement to the gaming experience and
remember there's new AMD offerings on
Route which we'll be seeing very very
soon okay let's talk about dss4 next as
at this point the 5070 needs all the
ammo it can get to fight off the
outgoing 470s super and of course
there's this Nvidia telling the world
that 5070 can offer 4090 performance
that means D lss4 multiframe generation
and that's already a bit of a house of
cards for NVIDIA bearing in mind prior
results in likeforlike testing on much
more capable Blackwell cards the FPS can
match and indeed exceed 490 but latency
definitely cannot But continuing on with
our prior 50 Series tests let's begin
with cyberpunk 2077 at 4K with rt
overdrive I'm going to skip the native
resolution testing because well RT
overdrive needs uh dlss super resolution
uh where we have a 40 FPS average with a
51 millisecond latency Forex multiframe
gen takes us up to 122 frames per second
which is nice but PC latency Rises up to
72 milliseconds so a 21 millisecond
deficit up against super resolution
that's moving somewhat into my
perception that something doesn't quite
feel right in the controls versus the
frame rate that I'm seeing on screen but
let's be clear here it is still playable
especially with a controller up against
the 1490 however running with 2x frame
gen 4X MFG on the 5070 well it offers
96% of 40/90 frame rate but the PC
latency at 72 milliseconds is 33
milliseconds higher than 1490 so again I
can't honestly call this ballpark 4090
Performance cyberpunk Based latency
isn't so bad though so it's a good basis
for using multiframe generation but Alan
Wake 2 is problematic The Benchmark here
gives us a 32.5 FPS frame rate with just
dlss super resolution along with an 83
millisecond latency
4X MFG gives a 3.35 X frame rate uplift
which is great but average latency in
the bench mark Rises to 108 milliseconds
which is not great base latency there is
just too high switching to 490
comparisons forx MFG on 5070 musters 90%
of 1490s frame rate with 2x frame gen
but it's the lag that's the killer a 67
millisecond average on 49 is already
high and having already established a
Forex MFG latency of 108 milliseconds
that's a 41 millisecond penalty so yeah
again not great not really comparable to
4090 despite what the frame rate numbers
might say so the 490 performance claims
are from my perspective dead in the
water really but that's not to say that
you can't use multiframe generation with
5070 with good results by dropping to
1440 P which let's face facts is a
better match for the 5070 and using alen
wake 2 with high rasterization settings
and low RT with direct lighting active I
had a pretty good time actually even in
really heavy areas of the game like this
one and with the dlss in Transformer
model mode at the balance settings with
3x MFG I achieved an experience that
would be a great fit for a high refresh
rate 1440p screen I use 3x MFG here in
instead of 4X and dialed back settings
in order to claw back as many
milliseconds as I could in terms of PC
latency uh Forex it's weird there isn't
actually a huge boost to latency but I
could start to feel the controls as
being a touch more sluggish and since
frame rate was already high anyway I
stuck to 3x MFG average latency across
all of my gameplay in this clip uh came
into about 53 milliseconds signif ific
anly better than the maxed experience on
4090 at 4K so yeah tweaking settings can
definitely improve the experience right
certainly in latency terms even if you
are losing some of the bling I chose a
similar strategy for playing cyberpunk
2077 with rt overdrive dlss again um a
3X multiframe gen mode with balanced
super resolution settings using the
Transformer model with average PC
latency at 45 milliseconds probably
could have pushed further but the
experience felt good and looked great
what's kind of nice here is that with
both Alan Wake 2 and cyberpunk a $550
GPU is providing a transformative
experience compared to consoles even PS5
Pro
dss4 and uh higher level rate tracing
are playing a big part in that of course
and as long as settings are judiciously
chosen um multiframe generation
technology works well so features are
important and Nvidia is pulling ahead of
the competition even as they are
starting to catch up in terms of Prior
generation Nvidia features um
Transformer model dlss super resolution
well that's a GameChanger and in a world
where High refresh rate monitors are
only getting more and more popular
multiframe generation definitely has a
role to play but ultimately Pure
Performance from the hardware well it
seems to be the case that as new
Blackwell cards appear the gains versus
4 40 series refresh are diminishing to
almost nothing and that's not good
regressions gen on gen that's actually
really bad I mean we saw it before to a
certain extent with 4060 TI versus 3060
TI but that was mostly on 4K Max
settings or other scenarios ill suited
to that level of card but here there are
scenarios where 4070 super can beat 5070
at
1440p or even 1080P and that's more than
a bit troubl
especially when we test relatively fewer
games than many other outlets so I would
expect to see more of these regressions
when you take a look at other reviews
from other channels so collating all of
our 1440p benchmarks we can use 507s
$550 MSRP to calculate value in the form
of dollars per frame but before I list
my caveats and concerns here's an
overall look at how the 5070 compares to
a range of gpus across a range of
resolutions expressed in the form of
percentage differentials collated from
all of our benchmarks but yeah dollars
per frame metx I hesitate to show those
results bearing in mind that 970 and 970
XT reviews are coming imminently and we
should expect the concept of price
versus performance to be disrupted based
on amd's promises and then again there's
also the concept of whether MSRP is
actually relevant anymore anyway here's
how the table looks a top 10 based on
cars from 70 series or equivalent up the
table kind of flatters the 5070 I guess
but the bottom line is this an
aggregated performance uplift of 4% over
470 super at
1440p combined with a Circa 8% reduction
in the MSRP puts the 5070 at the top of
the table 4070 super is beaten only by
the 570 TI in the overall value Stakes
followed by the one two of 7800 XT and
perhaps surprisingly the 7700 XT from
AMD now this doesn't reflect current
retail prices of course nor
availability um it's actually extremely
hard to get any prior generation Nvidia
offering at this point while AMD prices
vary dramatically but it does give you
some idea of how the concept of value is
scaling across time and as we move from
generation to generation cost per frame
is reducing but not in a particularly
quick manner but as I said expect the
rdna 4 cards to disrupt this table
somewhat and so in summary 5070 is well
I guess kind of underbaked a card of
this class should have more memory at
the very least but 12 GB it is um
underwhelming I'd say it should not be
outperformed by its predecessor in any
reasonable gaming scenario and yet it is
um you kind of hope that gen on genen
gains should improve as we go down the
stack um yet the 5070 is palpably worse
than the 5070 TI which didn't really set
the house on fire there either value is
indeed increasing with the uh cheaper
cards but not to a dramatically
meaningful degree looking at the
positives I mean I like the founders
edition board nicely made reasonably
quiet high quality materials I like dss4
even if its application requires a bit
more care than higher spec cards but
otherwise I guess I remain unmoved by
this release and kind of think Nvidia
should have done better that's all for
me for now so allow me to switch into
autopilot mode for this last part of the
video liking subscribing sharing bell
ringing for notifications on new DF
content this is all very good stuff as
is the DF supporter program of course
your support makes what we do possible
and what you get in return consists of
high quality video downloads of
everything we've done since late 2016
Early Access to content that includes DF
direct weekly and other videos too and
of course weekly updates from the team
it's all good stuff but that's all from
me on this one so as always thanks for
watching and supporting digital Foundry